une nouvelle chasse bonjour vous êtes en
direct de Kiev pour France 24 les dégâts
là-bas sera considérable
dans la région d'Odessa vous l'avez
mentionné c'est une vingtaine de drones
qui donc pendant trois heures
volaient dans le ciel
ukrainien la défense ukrainiennes la
défense entière a assuré en avoir abattu
neuf mais il y en a d'autres qui ont
apparemment continué leurs cours et il y
a des dégâts dans le sud de la région
d'Odessa encore une fois ce sont les
infrastructures portuaires notamment
celle du Danube qui ont été visés il y a
au moins un entrepôts céréaliers qui a
pris feu donc les conséquences ça veut
dire qu'il y a des milliers de kilos
voire des tonnes de céréales qui ne sont
plus utilisables et surtout qui ne sont
plus exportables puisqu'il faut savoir
que depuis que la Russie a quitté
l'accord céréalier de la mer Noire et
bien la Russie
régulièrement régulièrement viser les
ports de la région sud de l'Ukraine les
ports d'Odessa
notamment et ceux du dernier que je
mentionnais donc non loin de la Roumanie
ça veut dire que les infrastructures
portuaires elles sont endommagées et ça
veut dire que l'Ukraine peut
difficilement les utiliser pour exporter
leur céréales alors que c'est peur du
Danube et bien ils étaient devenus
essentiels à son export à son commerce
depuis le blocus imposé par la Russie en
mer Noire des attaques au drôles
également en territoire russe je le
mentionnais dans les titres à Belgorod
ou d'après les autorités 3 civiles
auraient été tués opération également
menée sur Moscou et sa région et ce pour
la sixième nuit consécutive Emmanuelle
il y a une intensification
absolument alors ce n'est pas surprenant
du côté ukrainien ça fait des mois que
le gouvernement prépare ce qui est
développe ce qu'il appelle une armée des
drones car le gouvernement ukrainien
l'armée ukrainienne ont très bien
compris que cette guerre se jouait aussi
avec ses nouvelles technologies et donc
cette guerre des drones que l'on voit
s'intensifier d'un côté comme de l'autre
puisque ça fait des mois que la Russie
lance des drones kamikazes sur l'Ukraine
depuis octobre dernier et bien cette
guerre elle s'intensifie aussi même si
on n'a pas forcément de revendications
systématique du côté ukrainien et même
si toutes les attaques de drone sur le
territoire russe ne peuvent pas être
imputés à l'Ukraine tout simplement
parce que certains drones requièrent des
technologies donc on ne sait pas si
l'Ukraine en bénéficie ou pas et bien
ces attaques s'intensifient non
seulement à Moscou vous l'avez mentionné
sixième nuit d'attaque consécutive mais
aussi sur des infrastructures
stratégiques pour les Russes comme ces
pans de Crimée qui avait été
visée plusieurs fois ou encore les ports
russes en mer Noire merci beaucoup pour
ces éléments Emmanuel Chaze à Kef pour
France 24